le 29 octobre 1999 après jésus-christ
c'est à dire aujourd'hui astérix fête
ses 40 ans l'irréductible petit gaulois
est en effet apparu pour la première
fois le 29 octobre 59 dans le tout
premier numéro du journal pilote
créé par goscinny et uderzo astérix est
aujourd'hui traduit en 85 langue
miracles de la bd en 40 ans de carrière
astérix obélix et idéfix n'ont pas pris
une seule ride
sabine gornik jean christophe duclos en
40 ans cette main là on a croqué des
milliers de petits gaulois ténu à
moustache et casques et les 290 millions
d'albums vendus par toutatis qui aurait
pu se douter le jour de la naissance
d'astérix dans le journal pilote de
pareil succès à croire que c'est papa
cosim il scénarise et uderzo sont tombé
dans la potion magique quand il était
petit c'est robin les maliens ont fait
un antihéros bon alors j'ai redessiner
un petit personnage comme il la voulait
et j'ai dessiné à côté lui un bonhomme
plutôt costaud encore une fois ça sent
pas pour lui faire faire je l'aimais un
mail hier sur le dos parce que riche
hoover bretagne et puis rené tout de
suite a senti que ce personnage pourrait
faire à faire valoir et ordinaire
toutatis olivier nous protège prenez des
gaulois forte tête
une armée de romain ajoutez-y des
bagarres des sangliers de la cervoise
saupoudré d'esprit gaulois et vous
comprendrez pourquoi dans la france des
années 60 envahi paris super héros
américain ces irréductibles ont vite
conquis le coeur des français
* oui disent que les gens connaissent et
astérix pognon je n'ai pas eu à bien
connaître un petit gaulois transforce
inc
c'est un peu tout le monde
on s'est amusé à jouer avec le
tempérament du français moyen
ils ont peur alors sachant pas voyager
critiquant toujours ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur et quand il est fait lui
fidic ancien chez lui ça c'est le truc
classique assez goalard en ce qui
concerne la bonne bouffe assez
dans la rhétorique je suis prêt depuis
l'entreprise astérix est devenue un
empire qui pèse son poids de sesterces
les produits dérivés sont légion un parc
d'attractions à son nom et dessin animé
un long métrage à succès et un 31e album
en préparation
bref du pain sur la planche à dessin
pour le papa d'astérix
si le ciel ne lui tombe pas sur la tête
et c'est la fin de set